Now I have to admit there's
a lot going on in this question.
At the end of the day,
we want to know how much we have to pay.
Well, that's a question of money and
money shows up here.
It's $6 for
each 24 ounce package of chicken wings.
Okay, so I guess that means I need to
know how many 24 ounce packages I need.
Which means I need to figure out
how much chicken I need to order.
Okay, well the first thing I want to
do is figure out how many pounds I'm
going to have to order.
And I know I'm getting 0.3 pounds per
person, which I can write like this, and
that there are 60 people.
So I'm going to multiply by 60 people.
Well, person, people,
same thing then they cancel out.
So I have 60 times 0.3 and
the only unit left is pounds.
And this works out to eighteen pounds.
Okay, so
I need to buy 18 pounds of chicken.
How many ounces is that?
Looks like I need to convert
to ounces to figure out
how many of these
packages I have to buy.
Well, I'm going to multiply
by my conversion factor,
which is going to be 16
ounces divided by one pound.
Again, my units cancel.
I'm left with 18 times 16 ounces.
Plug that into my calculator, and I find
that I need 288 ounces of chicken wings
and I should point out that, normally
I'd be doing this all on separate lines.
And that's how you should
be doing it in your book.
I just want to make sure this
all stays on the same page, so
I'm being a little bit sloppier
than I normally should be.
So we need 288 ounces of chicken.
How many packages is that?
Well,l I could just think of
this is dividing 288 by 24 and
that would give me the answer.
But as long as we're thinking
in terms of conversion factors,
I want to write it like this.
Times one package over
24 ounces of chicken.
And again, units cancel.
Ounces of chicken go away.
But now I have to multiply by 1 over 24.
Which, again,
is just like dividing by 24.
And the unit I have left is package.
So I get 12 packages of chicken.
Now how much do I have to pay?
Well, it's $6 per package.
I can even think of that as
being a conversion factor.
Package cancels, and I'm left with $72.
And that's the answer
you should have gotten.
And if you didn't,
believe me, I understand.
There was a lot going on here.
I would re-watch this video and
see if you can make sense of all of
the different uses of conversion factors
because there were a ton in here.
Once you can get to the point
where you can answer this question
without seeing the solution video,
well, you're good to go.